la celebración de una reconquista El
regreso del ejército ucraniano a la
ciudad de gerson ha sido catalogado como
la mayor victoria de kiev desde que
inició la invasión hace 8 meses Rusia
dijo que retiró a más de 30.000
militares de la urbe hacia la otra
orilla del río
niéperable los ciudadanos esperaron
nunca repudiaron a Ucrania tenían razón
al depositar sus esperanzas en Ucrania y
Ucrania siempre devuelve las suyas me
alegra ver a esa gente a pesar de todos
los peligros la represión y el
sufrimiento infligido por los ocupantes
que se aferran a las banderas ucranianas
en el centro de kiev cientos se
reunieron el viernes por la noche para
celebrar la noticia muchos son
originarios de gerson pero que huyeron
cuando las fuerzas rusas los invadieron
en marzo
muchos empiezan a regresar a sus hogares
o lo que queda de ellos los rusos
destruyeron y saquearon casas pero no
todo se fueron como esta granjera que
recuerdan los angustiosos momentos que
vivió durante la ocupación
nos hicieron entendernos en el camino
nos golpeaban con las culatas de los
rifles los rusos dañaron las casas de
luz que sirvieron a su ejército y se
llevaron los bienes de las mejores casas
jerson fue la única gran ciudad
ucraniana en caer en manos enemigas
Rusia sigue controlando alrededor del
60% de la región que lleva el mismo
nombre incluida la costa del mar de azul
y que fue anexionada ilegalmente junto a
otras tres por Moscú el principal punto
de acceso a la ciudad cruzando el río
nieper era el puente anthonynsky ahora
destruido según lo confirmado por
imágenes satelitales imágenes que
también señalan nuevos daños en La
Represa de novaka al norte de gerson y
cuya eventual voladura generaría
desastrosas inundaciones en el país